very cheery service from the old fellow
in an open mixture black man fort is
renowned food critic to be on excellent
terms with the mostly Cod Jewish lunch
his prank reviews have made unbroken
many businesses and he came away with
some strong opinions about the purple
Palace overall impressions were they
informative on the menu there was no the
old codger who was he was absolute he
was sweet he was very nice to my
daughter
he's very informative he was clearly
taking page in all he was doing and
style of food modern European I would
say and really very competently done it
was working some well-known combinations
every now and it just gets a bit too
fancy and I think maybe to justify them
no the dining room there was deep fried
rocket which I thought was been weird
what the [ __ ] we want to be frightful
you ask me I wish I'd if I was just a
restaurant critic I didn't know there
are these things
what gaze on his chef sense friendly
there's a mystery to all frequented
themselves